good afternoon everyone and welcome to
another live interview from the european
parliament here in brussels novaya
cassette one of the most important
independent media outlets of russia has
recently announced its decision to house
its publications until the end of
russian's invasion invasion of ukraine
today i'm very pleased to welcome its
deputy director its deputy editor kirill
martinov who will tell us about this
information and journalism in russia as
well as the more in moscow as he sees it
so first of all mr martino
i am welcome to have you here today
thank you for for a long time thank you
so much yes
before we get on underway with the
interview i'd like our followers to send
us their questions and comments and i'll
try to put as many as possible to my
guest in the next half an hour or so
so mr martinoff this morning you you met
the political leaders of the european
parliament what message did you deliver
to them
well i said them that they are basically
doing great because mr putin of course
president putin believed that western is
weak west west is weak and european
union in particular is weak
organization that
europeans just just can't
can fight and can fight against this war
and i feel like we and everyone
understand besides maybe president putin
himself that
he was wrong already and that the
european unity in your european support
for ukraine is
is
unpredictable is as high as
as it can be possible because
economical economical strike
of sanctions on russian economy is very
huge every person in russia feels now
and i feel like
like kremlin regime
would have a very big social and
economical problems within weeks or
maybe months and also also i told
parliament that
that
i feel like we have the only one dream
for now me and my fellow journalists
which can now
which which can't work in russia for now
we have only one dream we want to fight
again to fight for freedom of speech and
i ask
parliament for support
what is the current mood like in moscow
now and how do
how widespread is russian support for
russia's invasion of ukraine
well it's complicated question i mean
the second part of it because we have no
no good
sociological data
you you can imagine if if you are a
citizen which
involved in war and officials said
everyone who is against war can face
criminal prosecution and i ask you what
do you think about war is it good enough
and you say no no no i don't want to say
and this is basically what happened when
we try to just to interview russians for
now because as my
as my
fellow sociologists my my friend said
they tried to call uh
30 000 of russians and ask about
so-called special operation and uh
29 000 of them was just declined to to
answer and so you can imagine what what
is the mood in russia uh so i feel like
there is a
group of russians which is of course
support war and this group is strong
because it uh works together with
russian state propaganda and it's kind
of
a kind of dance macabre
dance of death which which is imposed on
ukraine and russian society too
the other group of russians i believe
they or we better to say we are strongly
against war we feel like we have a
personal responsibility and personal
duty to stop this war and we we
will find we will spend our
we spent our time we spent our days to
find some solutions how we can do this
what we can do else to stop this war you
have we have no uh mass protests in
russia because people just afraid and
the third and largest group of russian
citizens is a kind of conformists people
who just don't understand what to do now
they they just pretend to be safe they
just to take care about their families
and i feel like we can we can fight for
for the mood of this largest group
basically and uh you know the real
problem for me like like journalists is
i believe that
the main problem is not not in in
in the question of sources of
independent information yes
most russians don't have access to
independent information yes it's huge
problem after we stop our publishing in
russia
there is no more independent large media
and they have russians have just only
state propaganda and it's it's a kind of
disaster of course for for society it's
it's totally blind for now but i feel
like russians still have information on
youtube
and on some other social media like
telegram
and the real problem here is
many russians and probably most of the
russians just don't want to do it they
don't want to see the truth because if
you if you uh if you get you see the
truth if you're if you
feel that
russian state and and president putin
and his army invaded ukraine and started
this crime and senseless war then you
have to ask yourself
what who are we who who are we because
because we all all our history books
teach us that russians are basically
good people uh we what we did we
defeated defeated nazis we bring uh we
stopped the the largest and most closed
war in the world history and uh this is
the center of our national mythology
it's the center of our national identity
and if you for now if you see truth
you can understand that you have no
rights no no rights to this historical
heritage you have to
find some new identity basically for
russians to to uh to see the truth about
war in ukraine is to uh
not to be themselves anymore and so they
just declined they just pretend just
nothing special has happened many
the main role in russian society they
they many of my compatriots most of them
still believe that normal life
will soon return
and it's absolutely absolutely senseless
belief and to follow up with your answer
um you mentioned that people can get uh
you can get information from youtube and
telegram but many of the social media
are now blocked right yeah
so how what's happening
and more and more you know you know it's
uh
in this very very in this disaster in
this very sad situation we have a lot of
small funny stories and one of them is
that what are we doing now it's an
extremistic community for russians so if
you use facebook for online translation
probably we are a part of a large
extremistic organization maybe
this parliament
nevada was one of the remaining
remaining independent news outlets
standing in moscow how did you decide to
disease its operations
at the uh until the end of russia
inauguration of ukraine well basically i
can't i can't speak i can describe all
the facts we have public because of the
safety reasons but i can said that uh
that
this warnings from uh russian censorship
agency roscommodore was just just a
formal uh formal thing here
because the real problem is we feel like
that in these days after
2028 of march
to continue publishing text in russia is
just too dangerous in terms of personal
safety of journalists and all staff of
nova gazette so we suspend the
publishing activity because we just feel
it's unsafe for for people because
people really can face criminal
prosecutions and of course it have
nothing common this law or moral and so
on because this criminal prosecution
can be uh can be traced just
just to
to our rights to to name war war so so
in russia for now it's it's criminal
persecution and it's still unbelievable
we
like like no one can imagine
besides of american intelligence and
president biden no one can really
imagine that putin can can did it i
personally didn't believe this because i
i feel like he can probably declare the
independency of so-called donetsk people
republic and then everything will will
be will stop but no one can uh can still
believe that no of journalists i mean
can still believe that you can just
you can just uh write war in in
newspaper because for example we covered
our newspaper covered two chichen wars
and it was a huge conflict inside
russian society and and with russian
authorities about this war but at that
times we can at least uh write about war
and call it war and for now it's just a
different state it's it's a kind of
tyranny probably
yeah so have you have yes said
well journalists cannot describe the
conflict as war or neither this invasion
right and also under the new law people
face up to 15 years of yale when they
spread information that they consider
false information so how do you how did
this affect your job and the job of
independent journalists in
russia i strongly believe that for now
there is no
opportunities to work in russia like an
independent journalist it's not just
unsafe it's it's it's become a bit
stupid because uh every of when you just
do your professional work you can face a
prison just for it not for some hero not
for some heroical you know attitude not
for not for
uh something uh um something great you
just you just go to your office and
after that you can can be arrested so
it's it's it's not
it's not just useful in in any sense and
i believe that for now many of russian
independent media
start uh to operate outside russia and
you know it's kind of
a kind of underground spice activities
because it's it's not not usual for
journalist of course and it's probably
against our professional ethics but you
can imagine that if you want to report
something about uh inside russia
you have
you have work anonymously you have no
name and you have no no no official
connections with this uh this media
so it's like like a like
underground operation for now and i feel
like it's it's a future of for russian
journalism for for next week's months
and maybe years but our editor-in-chief
dmitry moratov who got nobel uh
yes last year he just a bit optimistic
here he believes that in some in some
situation we can probably start to
operate in moscow legally again i'm not
sure about this but
i
appreciate his opinion of course
well so we were mentioning before um how
people get informed now in russia did
the number of readers of novalia gazeta
change in the last month oh yes it was
absolute record in our history because
only on our website and we
don't uh count
social media
public here
so we have more than uh
two millions of people daily on our
website only and of course it's it's a
very large uh uh
public interest because you can imagine
if if people go to a website you know
that that your your your headlines uh
spreading a lot wider because of social
media and many people just discuss this
so i feel like we also we in this case
we really was a
national scale newspaper for russia and
we i'm very proud of our journalists
because we we uh did it
longer than any so so we we we was the
last independent media we decided to
suspend it activities because of safety
reason but we do it after 30 uh 34
days after the outbreak of war
we have a live question from one of our
viewers well you mentioned briefly that
we
you cannot really
track how many people are aware of the
situation in
ukraine but in david may in on youtube
says what percentage of the russian
people know what's going on
oh sorry would a percentage of the
russian people know what's going on
percentage
number of people or like well i believe
millions of them and you know if if
let's say for official official date
data said that uh one quarter of
russians do not support war and if we if
we count childs one quarter of russians
it's 36 millions and i believe that
a lot of more people understand what's
happening so let's say let's say maybe
half of russia but but you know it's
it's uh for many people it's just too
too hard to real to to say it public and
to to to understand what happened in in
terms of national identity we described
later
was one of the only russian newspapers
and russian news outlets with a
correspondence in the front line yeah
very proud of it yes but will this
person continue working there
uh
i'm not sure i can i can say it but but
probably for now yes because i i i
thought with selena kostichenko
brilliant now best reporter which was uh
she's incredible
brave journalist she worked for the
whole month in ukraine she twice crossed
the front line when he go to a cupid
city of her son and after that go back
to ukraine territory she uh worked there
with russian passport you know russian
passport is not so
not so many big value of these days in
ukraine and in and even in europe
and i told this he was here yesterday
and she said she's quitting now she
needs a break and we have another
reporter which will uh who is we will
continue to work
and the the the question is where we
have to publish his text but i think we
can somehow solve it okay yeah so mr
martinez i'd like to to read one of the
comments from our audience this comes
from marika and she has just posted in
youtube
martinoff is a remarkable scholar
philosopher and journalist novalia
gazetta has paid the price to tell its
readers the truth with the with the life
of six of its journalists thanks to
novalia from
from bulgaria i really appreciate this
kind of kind word thank you so much
and also
adrian on facebook says do you think
putin is capable to use the nuclear
weapons
uh basically yes and it was really
strange to realize this just because a
month ago just because if he came to
start this war why he can't to not just
to raise stakes even more and of course
it was in in his in his wars and in his
eyes it would just be a case for
defending our homeland from the evil
empire empire of lies how he described
this these institutions for example
uh
uh two days ago dmitry piskov the press
secretary of putin said that
they does not believe that
nuclear wars can be
using of nuclear war can be uh possible
in case uh of special operation and it
was you know it was a kind of
liberalization of the discourse maybe
just because they they were situation is
not so good for for russian side
so mr martino if you are here in
brussels today what can what can the
european union do to help russian
journalists speaking against putin's
regime and committed to reporting the
truth
i believe we need an example
we need an example of different
countries that what works together that
support each other that don't go to war
that probably
the authorities of which probably
uh read uh count some somehow and know
that that war is not so good solution
and we
need
an example for stronger values
and
this unity unity of values and after
that after that i believe if we share
these common values we can we can
we can have a lot of
good media and cultural projects and we
we have to solve how to
work in this situation uh how to
continue to work in this situation and
basically how to deliver our information
to the white public inside russia and i
i feel like uh european union is union
has already
uh
do this job
with with
nova gazette with
other russian journalists in exile uh
like like those like uh what's what's
remaining of a hamas lee which was
which was banned by by
by the owner of the of the company of
the media company
uh
i feel like we have a good uh good
efforts
um and how will you continue your
journalistic work and plus how do you
intend to continue with the work of
novaya cassita well you know for safety
reason i can't uh can't answer this
question i'm sorry but i feel like we we
don't stop we don't stop and we you know
yeah i
talked with uh
with a guy from bbc who who just
say probably you have some journalistic
this kind of media instincts which which
brings you further and and i i said yes
it's good good uh good you know these
days when we can publish our texts i
just just looks for for
news like always
every morning and i just think what what
reporter can do this news what what who
can cover this story for us and after
that i realized oh we have for now these
days we have no newspaper what to do but
i believe this instincts uh will bring
us further and i believe we we will come
back and i hope this
uh this
this resurrection of nova gazita would
be nice and
and we can continue these traditions of
politkowska
and
all of our
other great reporters but uh i've just
learned from our viewer that you are
also a philosopher yeah so have you ever
worked as such uh sorry have you ever
worked as a philosopher yes i i worked
like a philosopher for the whole of my
life and i was
first i was fired from higher school of
economics two years ago because of
criticizing of president putin
and after that we created a new project
with our our
professors this was fired from uh higher
school for economics it calls free
moscow university it's a kind of online
university in exile and we for now we
are looking for opportunities to
communicate with european institutions
and i feel like we have good
opportunities for now we are strongly
like this institution like free
university we are strongly against war
students teachers and ourselves
self-government supported this position
it i'm very proud about this
and you know it's again it's a small
funny story for me because just as in
the start of this uh is in
at the start of march i was
fired twice two times or three times
from different russian state educational
institutions in moscow it was it was
simple like this you just come
the war started you just came to
students and you you tell them
war is bad
we're going to fight against war peace
is much better and then so on such as
such simple ways and after that someone
someone in administration tell you you
know it's too dangerous for us to have
such a teacher in our university can you
somehow
pretend that you live on your own just
we have no no prosecution for you and
for us
and i said of course of course it's it's
what it's my duty to to to live in this
situation and
i i feel like we we have some sources
some instruments to recreate
partly
uh this educational
system uh educational space for russian
students and many of my former students
i teach
i teach
in official russian institutions they
for now they are students in free moscow
university
and i feel like it's only the beginning
so i you know i like this story about
philosophy philosopher riots
we discussed newspaper rights and for
now and
newspaper writes at the special term
because
for me because
we have we got a lot of help from
different newspapers around the globe
from american
newspapers they they offer us to publish
our texts on their pages and then
writing philosophers that's what i
always like so it's a good opportunity
for me
[Music]
parliament special committee on foreign
interference has recently called for
sanctions on foreign interference and
information manipulation what could the
european union do to tackle both this
information in russia and
in the european union as well
well i believe that we have to i mean
they have to support uh
those people who whose for those
organizations who
are struggling against this information
i feel like no this this uh this kind of
work uh they do a lot of this
information but we checked this and said
no that was this information it's a good
it's a good instrumental solution good
good solution in the narrow narrow sense
of world but uh what what i believe we
have to recreate
uh
media media sphere for russia we have we
have we need television we need
independent radio stations we need
independent
websites and maybe even illegal printing
printing
printing newspapers inside russia and i
feel a lot of people just want to do it
so so i feel like we can communicate
with the european union and try to do it
together because we have common
interests we don't like
this information either
so the best solution for this
information is information
it's true yeah
so mr martinez thank you very much for
your time today we really appreciate it
and i wish you all the best for your
future work
please remember that at 2 p.m if you
want to know more about this information
in the light of
russia's
invasion of ukraine you can tune in in
the european parliament website because
there will be a webinar for journalists
on this information yes and
a member of the parliamentary rafael
glue gluckman and other speakers will be
talking about it
so thank you all of you to for tuning in
once again and have a good afternoon
you